[Music]
good evening I'm Bret Baier President
Trump says the US will let someone else
fight over quote the long blood-stained
sand in the Middle East he's announcing
what he calls a permanent ceasefire
between Turkey and Syrian based Kurds
the president is lauding the effort as
an outcome reached without spilling one
drop of American blood his critics on
Capitol Hill though especially about
this porn foreign policy move do not
agree that this is a major breakthrough
chief White House correspondent John
Roberts starts off tonight on the North
Lawn getting jump ragged evening to you
President Trump was cautious today
saying that it is too early for
congratulations adding that the
definition of permanent in that part of
the world is questionable but for the
moment at least he was only too happy to
take the apparent win
President Trump declared victory for his
foreign policy today announcing that
Turkey had agreed to make the five day
long ceasefire with Kurdish forces in
Syria permanent I greet you this morning
from the White House to announce a major
breakthrough toward achieving a better
future for Syria and for the Middle East
President Trump also lifted sanctions he
imposed on Turkey but added a permanent
solution to the Turkish Kurd conflict
would not have been possible without the
fighting that erupted after the invasion
the pain and suffering of the three-day
fight that occurred was directly
responsible for our ability to make an
agreement with Turkey and the Kurds that
could never have been made without this
short-term outburst president Trump is
leaving it to Turkey and Russia to
patrol the 20-mile safe zone established
in the agreement South Carolina Senator
Lindsey Graham praised the ceasefire but
worried about what comes next I agree
with the president without sanctions
there would have been no ceasefire but
you cannot rely on Syria Russia or
turkey to protect the United States
against Isis the president appeared to
get buy-in from the Kurds Syrian
democratic forces leader general [ __ ]
tweeting quote we thanked President
Trump for his tireless efforts that
stopped the brutal Turkish attack and
jihadist groups on our
people but Democrats continued to hammer
president Trump Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer worried about a possible
resurgence of Isis in the blink of an
eye
President Trump has undone over five
years of progress against the Islamic
state President Trump today played down
any threat from Isis members who escaped
captivity during the fighting there were
a few that got out a small number
relatively speaking and they've been
largely recaptured the president also
confirmed a small contingent of US
forces would remain in eastern Syria to
protect the oil fields igniting a sharp
response from senator Bernie Sanders who
tweeted last I checked Congress never
authorized US forces to be deployed to
secure serious economic resources
putting US forces in harm's way for this
purpose is illegal and unconstitutional
even president Trump's special envoy to
Syria Jim Jeffrey was unclear today
about what will happen what are we gonna
do with these oil fields that's a really
good question and we're really working
hard on it but we do not have an answer
at this time
Jeffrey also told a House committee
today that the United States has no idea
we're about a hundred Isis fighters who
escaped custody
currently our and Jeffrey appeared to
contradict the president's claims a
victory when he likened the turkish
incursion to a tragedy that it had been
official US policy of the past two
administration's to avoid Brett John
Roberts live in the North Lawn John
thanks a Bible